les cernant le mytho c'est des mecs coût
des meufs qui raconte à tout le monde
des trucs qui n'ont jamais fait en
permanence un serial mythos ne peut pas
à mentir sur un mensonge de trop clair
et net
comme par exemple bonjour je suis robbie
williams
ça c'est pas possible parce que c'est
vérifiable dans le présent tout de suite
mais le problème c'est que pour pas les
vexer on est obligé de faire semblant de
les croire mon grand cousin il a une
jaguar et à des fois il me l'a prête
genre à un faible à prêter je suis allé
sur l'autoroute et j'ai eu un accident
et la voiture elle a fait des tonneaux
et tout à fait d'accord et waouh t'es
pas blessé quand même un peu parce que
normalement ça tue des gens ou un truc
comme ça
bah non parce que si tu veux dans les
jaguars thaddée des airbags et tout le
sport quand tu cherche la petite bête
qui essaient de leur prouver que ce
qu'ils disent les complètement faux il
utilise une technique très spécial mois
une fois que ma soeur pour se marrer on
a avalé du plomb ban on regarde si tu
avales du plomb tumeur directement comme
le prouvent précisément ce livre de
science brevetée par la nasa
la technique du jeu sait plus trop à
temps anne en fait ce n'est pas
justement du plomb je crois c'était un
autre métal où j'ai plus trop enfin bon
on s'en fout sur le sujet allez what is
de fugue de pire c'est que c'est souvent
quand toi tu raconte un truc devrait
quitter
après mon arrivée que ça leur donne
envie de surenchérir sur un mytho pour
être encore plus fort que toi moi j'ai
un pote qui qui parle bien anglais et
qui en plus ce dernier a pas mal en
espagnol ah ouais bah moi ça me fait
penser justement j'ai un pote lui parle
carrément neuf langues
comme par hasard des fois je me demande
comment ça ferait 2000 toki qui se rend
compte et qu'ils discutent bas ma soeur
elle parle 21e langues
ah ouais et ben moi quand j'ai fait
l'armée il y avait un mec qui parlait 28
milliards de langues
en même temps ça sert à rien lessard et
le mytho ils auront toujours le dernier
mot ouais si tu veux moi j'ai bossé aux
states à pendant un an en tant que
directeur de projet photo af c'est
bizarre parce que maintenant tu tu
travaille en tant que stagiaire dans les
magasins shopi ouais mais si tu veux aux
states à aucun rapport n'a aucun rapport
avec la france parce que les métiers
c'est pas la même échelle
moi quand j'étais petit j'avais un cui
de 253 je crois j'étais joueur surdoué
et puis depuis j'ai tout perdu et
maintenant je redevenue normale
[Musique]
abonne toi ma chaîne youtube en cliquant
ici
et tente sa chance pour peut-être gagner
le détecteur de mensonges de macgyver
du balai les salades mito pas mal et ça
c'est une sorte de ballet quoi